with a running time of about two and a
half hours Captain America Civil War is
one stuff movie it features about for
action have you set pieces a dozen
superheroes beating each other up
political machinations and even a couple
bromances thrown in for good measure
as a result some scenes just had to hit
the cutting room floor
as ever beware spoilers ahead meet
ant-man when we meet ant-man before the
big super throwdown at the airport in
Germany he more or less jumps out of the
van and shakes hands with Captain
America but as it turns out the tiny
hero's introduction in the script was
originally well bigger get it because he
grows he grows big according to a / film
interview with civil war screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
the script originally called for a scene
with Lang in the gang in his home in San
Francisco but it was deleted because it
didn't get ant-man stone quite right
Marcos explained we were probably wrong
because of the nature of when we started
making the movie versus when it came out
as we were doing it for infinity war we
wrote a lot if not all of Scott Lang
stuff before we ever saw ant-man you
just have to roll with that because we
need to film
where's wasp speaking of ant-man fans
were excited by the movie's post-credit
scene that alluded to the impending
debut of the heroes crime-fighting
partner the wasp
I mean maybe she'd appeared with ant-man
in civil war right that's apparently
something that filmmakers actually
wanted to happen
but Marvel Studios had Kevin Feige
explained it was more important to
preserve her superhero journey for the
ant-man sequel talk it out after the
Winter Soldier is captured in Germany
the heroes gather and discuss what's
going on these scenes continue to inform
who's on which side of the movies
conflict and why but civil wars
directors Joe and Anthony Russo decided
that not all conversations are created
equally Joe Russo explained to
comic-book comm that a black widow and
black panther chat was cut to keep
things rolling there was a scene between
Natasha and T'Challa at the German ops
center halfway through the movie when he
was sitting in that room cap and Falcon
have been isolated in the other
conference room we didn't feel like it
was moving the storytelling forward and
they had already had a scene so it felt
repetitive so was something we excised
from the movie cap dies the end of
Captain America civil war shows cap
ultimately winning his brawl with Iron
Man and living to fight another day
but at the end of the comic book version
of Civil War cat meets his maker as it
happens a Screen Rant
interview with screenwriters McFeely and
Marcus reveals that they never even
considered often Captain America killing
off cap said McFeely would have undercut
the ambiguity they were aiming for with
the issues presented by the sokovia
accords it also makes him - definitely a
martyr and makes it feel like he was
right and we wanted neither side to be
right or wrong we wanted to end it kind
of queasy both of things are still
standing at the end of the movie and
considering how great the final film
turned out it's pretty hard to argue
with their decision thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which deleted scene you would have
liked to see most